Suzette's gosh what's for review
guys I changed my mind I hate this I do
ty despise it it's the worst movie ever
it's my favorite Marvel movie damn art
paintings have really changed since we
did our non-spoiler review no I still
feel the same way about as I did before
we haven't seen our non-spoiler I'm Greg
John if you haven't seen their
non-spoiler review Suicide Squad go
check that out I guess we gave a basic
summary without having a feeling like
gonna cover the whole thing again
everybody capsuleer under on tomatoes is
correct positive or negative everything
shoppi messy all over the place chaotic
but also a lot of fun let's get into
this but I want to start off with same
one thing the line that Will Smith
delivers we're some kind of Suicide
Squad in the trailer the first trailer
that looked like so cheesy it's so
horrible
oh my god that he really just do the
title of the movie thing in the actual
movie this scene that they do that is it
it actually doesn't come across that way
we're I'm like up that be said that
title of the movie it sounded like a
natural line read so Will Smith good job
on that it's the hardest movie I'm
thoroughly enjoyed it from beginning to
end a lot of people I know complained
about the beginning how there's like two
intros to Deadshot and Harley Quinn then
he had hot water than they read use that
just but I was actually okay with it cuz
I like this scene with that shot and
Harley Quinn yeah because it wasn't
about Deadshot and Harley Quinn they're
introducing they're introducing Griggs
Ike Barinholtz character that was like
one of the main things was that
interaction between them it wasn't just
about Deadshot and Harley Quinn well
yeah you get to know them as prisoners
and then you get to know them
know them before yeah and they're just
establishing that they're gonna be the
most focused on people of the Suicide
Squad which is nothing wrong with that
yeah people I feel like it was like the
big prom I don't even but I didn't find
it wow it is like it's just the editing
to me again it is it isn't even as it
appears on the screen I'll give you
that's not something I necessarily want
to blame on you know the conception of
the the community but it's fun and I
give it I give it credit because in
those first two scenes before Amanda
Waller
I was like I am I like them all right
yeah
like I thought it will Smith I
immediately it'll change my whole
opinion about the idea that he's in this
movie from that one scene he's really
naturally he feels just like an older
you know more gruff Will Smith but he's
still the Will Smith you love feels like
the charming guy who will [ __ ] you up
this time yeah yeah and he has an edge
but it's believed like he really sells
Deadshot at Margot Robbie really sells
Harley Quinn and Harley Quinn when you
see her like how she's like [ __ ]
around in her prison cell and she's
trying to lure in Ike Barinholtz that
was a cool moment because you get a
history sense that like oh they probably
done some like abusive stuff - Harley
since yeah they probably all it just
seems like that pervert prison guard you
know that guy in Terminator 2 like takes
advantage of Sarah Connor barren old
history that's movie when he's on the
rooftop showing how he does his job that
way that was done sets it up totally in
a in a right way for me where I'm like
this is kind of funny and this is a
different kind of hitman scenario yeah
because of the way how he's handling it
and then he does get his one-shot kill
and I thought that shot would have been
cooler if he if there was like blood and
stuffing Oligocene one who wants to be
rated R and that's the thing about a lot
of pg-13 action movies now and comic
book movies like this movie does have
this sort of like faceless creature
villains after a while that make it so
that there's not actual blood we all
know what that looks like and so you
find yourself missing it that's a point
that you made before it's like it would
make us feel more in touch with the fact
he's a bad guy if we could see the blood
the moment with it with him and his
daughter I thought was really nice too
because it didn't seem like some force
like really care about Deadshot moment
here the fact that he's a dad
yeah interaction you know seemed rather
natural and the way it was done and that
Batman shows up and it kind of reminded
me of like a CW show where like takes
place within the Batman universe yeah
yeah and that was a cool scene and like
you it really does the the relationship
between Deadshot and his daughter is so
vital to the story of Deadshot and
especially in that moment because the
only reason he could have shot Batman
easily yeah but his daughter saved a
man's life that's something I was really
happy about with this movie cuz those
those are the kinds of scenes that are
easy to just make wrote and requisite
and
yeah don't care cuz hey every they have
always got a daughter or a wife or
something but this movie really sells
that partly in the way it's constructed
cuz it's important to his story and the
choices he makes but also cuz Will
Smith's performance and Margot Robbie
had a very challenging job I feel when
she's just dr. Quinzel it's a different
performance and it has to be and it has
to be still like matching something
where you can see this was the original
source of art but the coin well I mean
when they do the flash for the fantasy
the showing you what you want moment
towards the end when she and Jared Leto
were just there as an as a real couple
they're like that's kind of a beautiful
moment and they she does have to play
those two different sides of the coin
and I like how they set up her character
like it was it fast where you know you
see that she does get transformed they
they show the transformation scene later
you see their dynamics where she's like
stripping in the animated series Joker
really seems like he doesn't care about
Harley Quinn really does yes sir and who
you sir but in this movie you could tell
Joker likes her again yeah love with her
and that was an interesting touch darks
psychotic love relationship
David arrows a guy who rides a lot of
crime stuff and I liked crime boss and
his crazy girlfriend Joker you know a
lot of people were complaining about the
scene where he like offers her to common
but it seems like they're both into that
in a way that seems like it suits the
Joker cuz it's all about seeing what
this guy's gonna do under a weird yeah I
did like that moment because it felt
like he was testing common yeah like
this is icky I'm supposed to be icky I
actually thought that was a cool scene
if I if I'm reading it the right way
yeah like I do wish the Joker got like
that's one of his few scenes where he
gets time to showcase some of his acting
yeah it's real acting abilities does a
younger Joker see yeah I like seeing the
Joker that they had in here where he's
kind of uh you know he is like the Clown
Prince of the underworld yeah you know
he feels like a gangster Coketown yeah
it feels like a like a punk rock coke
down meth addict kind of gangster you
know yeah and and and he's got the you
know the grill and stuff like he looks
freaky and imposing in a crime boss kind
of way like the crime Side of Gotham of
the DC Universe
is something distinct and I thought they
brought that back with this what a lot
of people are talking about too is when
Harley gets rescued by Batman and then
he like gives her CPR but it was weird
to me is like I know he was doing her
CPR then I'm hardly stressed kissing him
it look like Batman was kissing her
okay good in the first time he does it I
was like look I thought he was just
kissing her I didn't think he was
actually giving her CPR no we're gonna
do the CPR intensely she's she's not I
do like that moment though where she's
attacking him underwater they just does
like this underwater punch to her face
and she not except and Captain Boomerang
the first few seconds you get a Captain
Boomerang
he's an assault on Jai Kourtney's whole
mannerisms I like that when they cuts
into characters they have like those
quick little character descriptions
around the around the sketch I did
alcohol like psychotic I'm a fan of the
flash series I'm a big fan of that show
so seeing flash show up like this I
thought was a way better flash cameo
than the one at bad pippy's Superman
yeah it was fun you get flashes
personality in there the cameos weren't
a hundred percent natural for me but
they did get closer to feeling like the
DC EU is kind of a big world and animus
resisted but cameos felt more fun too
yeah yeah they're they're a lot better
than just reading some by the end of
that little moment with the flash of a
cat hey Captain Boomerang man Jai
Courtney I wish they gave him more to do
cuz it's the first time I've been
thrilled to see him that's the one
problem with Captain Boomerang in this
film is that he's funny he's really
entertaining but he's overall very
unnecessary to the suicide a lot and and
that's the thing that I think it gets
lost in the crazy whatever happened with
the editing that all gets lost cuz a lot
of characters end up feeling like they
were supposed to be more important or
they were supposed to have more time to
grow a relationship together cuz he's
Captain Boomerang doesn't get it you
show off anything makes him unique you
get to see his unique personality
boomerang skills don't really get to be
at play here there's one moment towards
the end where they like attached to a
camera or something whether you like
throws the boomerang but that's it and
that's late in the movie so you're like
oh I guess they're gonna finally when
it's convenient sort of explain what he
might have to do
because especially in that last fight it
seems like they mostly have to protect
it and it was cool of how they made
Batman cameo because you know like in
the in the mid credit scene you see
though he Bruce Wayne here he's talking
to Amanda Waller but before that any
time you saw Batman he was just Batman
then no one knew him as Bruce Wayne yeah
so it was cool to have that like Batman
kind of mystique about him that's what I
really liked about what they did with
that man because sure it's cameos cameos
but they were done in a way where you
kind of do see him through the image of
the villains of how they would view
Batman yeah that that is a cool side of
the coin see that from did does she know
that he's Batman
he might Waller yeah yeah she's that's
what she's giving him like the reporting
sure absolutely sure I killed a croc in
this movie I I know that other than the
animated series he's not the most
intelligible guy I put a lot of the
issues of this film on the editing but I
feel like script had a lot to do with
his character too there are some things
I think yeah the script it could have
gotten better and I never got the sense
that Killer Croc was supposed to do more
and I got the sense for a lot of other
kids you think they hint at Killer Croc
like he left Gotham because he got
pushed out of Gotham by Batman I thought
I've been cool to get like a cool Batman
Killer Croc how when Batman it's really
sweet by next his well captured moment
and everything is not really that cool
and then throughout the whole movie he
doesn't talk his powers because he's
like super-strength and stuff yeah they
don't really get shown off that much you
know his reptile skills being able to
breathe underwater and everything that
comes in very late towards the film
yeah and prior to that moment I was like
Killer Croc seems very unnecessary they
seemed like I could have just been
replaced by soldiers that was one of my
prompts with this film when you're glad
they're there cuz they're cool and we
want to see them but they don't add a
whole lot else there's nothing unique
about them to the point that serves
value like yeah we need this Suicide
Squad it really just seemed like they
needed Deadshot yeah Deadshot Harley
Quinn and and and then El Diablo becomes
important later and see I almost feel
like everybody was supposed to be
introduced up front except maybe
yeah we could go why do we not know this
yeah yeah you know I really do get the
sense that they were supposed to expound
on more of these characters and then
they just kind of shoved him around and
made it sort of clear that it's just
Deadshot and Harley Quinn and I think
what they do with El Diablo was a lot of
fun actually you know like they said
they set up that you know ye had this
dark pass and he won't be that guy
anymore
one issue with that is you do make El
Diablo a good guy at that moment you
hint that he had a darker pass you don't
find out so that bar scene that like oh
there's the really [ __ ] up thing that
he did was a great scene it's a great
scene but you know like you do sent him
up as a guy I think as the person who is
a good guy now who only fight for when
it's something right you know yeah you
do
cuz ain't is where you meet him as you
know he's like I don't do that anymore
you know peace
I like the effects like I love the fire
effects they do yeah when he becomes
like super Diablo [ __ ] that whatever
yeah yeah that was pretty cool I was a
little bit like huh like it took me a
second to swallow that but it is cool I
feel like it would have worked really
well too if they took like the
witchcraft stuff and like that el Diablo
kind of moment and enchantress his
brother was an incubus or something like
that stuff seemed totally out of place a
lot of the time because and out of place
in the plot - yeah I feel like it could
have been spread out if it was spread
out more throughout like the vibe of it
and the themes of them spread out more
cuz whatever it cut to them it was like
oh this is a totally different genre of
the film and that's where the plot gets
confusing because it I can't for the
life of me remember what why she was
assembling is she just assembling the
suicide squad to go get metahumans or
whatever and bring him in that's what's
confusing is because the idea that's set
up you know she's saying that like what
if the next Superman decides to do
something horrible say so they need
metahumans to fight against you know
like other metahumans no one on the
Suicide Squad is really metahuman except
for Diablo yeah and that's about I guess
killer across sort of he's technically
yeah but everyone Deadshot Harley Quinn
Slipknot even and Slipknot fan that was
that
it's probably a big let that was like
the Johnny Cage moment in Mortal Kombat
annihilation like oh this guy ain't
gonna do anything he literally is here
to prove that no one's [ __ ] yeah
something chanters was cool I like the
intro that they had within Tran trust
yeah like she became inch Atris the
effects were really creepy in me and but
the stuff with her brother was just like
I don't know it was a little too much
where she grabbed a like a face was just
like a random dude and then turned him
into a big robot that looks kind of like
that other robot yeah but I was telling
John we were walking out was like I
really feel like editing could have in
terms of like just placement of scenes
could have helped this movie out a lot
because by the time that Enchantress
stuff starts getting [ __ ] wacko it's
pretty late into the film where the
tonally is like little jarring yeah and
and when it becomes a major problem the
movies are jumbled enough that you start
to wonder if it makes any sense than
this is their mission now it forces you
to kind of catch yourself and
reconfigure the plot in your mind and
yeah it's like I like the first half of
the Enchantress story and not really the
second half and that's a complaint that
I would give to the script it's like
we've seen the whole human being suck
let's create a machine to kill all of
them and yeah well I'm like I'm so tired
in the sky' portal like it's always it's
always a Skye portal now and I'm like
don't do this guy's portal anymore see
what I thought would have been really
cool that honestly if I were to like
help out with editing yeah there's a
scene where they're all in the
helicopter the suicide squads been
assembled katanas part on the tee is on
the team now too
and then when they're flying into the
city you know Harley Quinn has outlined
like oh look at the pretty lights and
stuff yeah and then you see like it's
chaos and destruction yeah but that's a
Harley Quinn line and then the plane
gets hit they crash and then I thought
that would have been a cool opening
scene like that whole segment right
there
plane crashes then cuts do one week
earlier and that's when it's the Amanda
Waller
you know like Trump I think dinner at
the dinner yeah perfect that would have
been perfect because it would have
totally set us up for something major
supernatural happening that they have to
go up against as opposed to this was in
kind of the world that I was prepared
for like the first trailer that came out
was the trailer for the actual David
Ayer movie it looks like all those
scenes were supposed to go on a little
bit longer you know see the thing that I
feel like where David Ayer probably
lacked in terms of writing is the
supernatural stuff is yes because you
know like what David Ayer deals with is
like raw real grit la kill person stuff
yeah but they're going places with Flagg
and all that and when they're in prison
and when they're on their way like that
yeah that's great like the dialect I
think it's why he writes all the human
characters very well el Diablo was
suppressing his powers for most of the
movie and I think he writes him really
well too so he writes like the criminal
character as well but when it comes to
the enchantress character her brother
and it's like that's just not David
Ayer's thing yeah that felt really like
you've you watched a couple comic book
movies yeah I think if you bump in
saying it kind of feels like it's not
ghostbusters a little bit and it kind of
does like humans suck I'm gonna kill
them yeah do I really like though there
are those Amash moments you know what I
[ __ ] love and they've brought it here
like that shower you quickly see Arkham
Asylum and like the title it's like and
then they have that moment where it's
all black with it Harley's dressed up in
her classic Harley Quinn outfit yeah and
Joker's in his suit like that they
brought that to light it I'm really
gratifying it is like whoa it does feel
like a fanfiction moment at that time it
does and I at first see I don't know I'd
like to see it again because I don't
know if those moments to me fully blend
in with the rest of the movie
however they are I know how iconic those
images are I've seen those you know
those paintings it's really cool to see
them you know it's really cool when they
do the whole Joker and Harley you know
jumping into the VAT thing like that was
great scene yeah it is like it's that
was well acted and well done and Harley
and Men well Margaret everyone's give us
Kolkata tomorrow - Robbie a lot for her
portrayal of Harley Quinn and you know
what she gets the animated personality
perfectly with just the right moments of
human touch just like I like how after
Joker's plan fails and then she's still
alive that she's crying but the second
the squad shows up she's like
I'm not gonna show them that I'm Safi
now because that was the one time we can
see Harley be a little emotional without
it being like that's not and I felt like
she did a good job of that of having a
lot of real moments in a bunch of very
different boots yeah like cuz cuz even
though things Harley says that
contradict you still kind of believe
them all yeah if she believes them all
at the time that's another thing that I
wish had kind of been more fleshed out
about this movies by the time they get
to the end and they care about each
other for some reason like yeah because
they've always spent a few hours
together yeah and like it's not even
been a day and they've only got the one
time to just sit and be together and
chat I thought Harley Quinn's moment of
saying like don't [ __ ] with my friends
were over she says to enchantress I
thought that was more believable than El
Diablo be like I already lost one family
yeah might you consider these guys
family already it seems like an ensemble
guy and I feel like they should have
really put some more attention on
building them as an ensemble yeah cuz
this movie kind of gets to it with it
introduces people and then it's like
we're moving and we're gonna fight a lot
of people and the militant the soldier
guys are gonna remind us that all these
guys are bad guys that's the one I felt
like it was going too much for a heroic
sense yes so just I felt like it would
have been fine if a 10 or not nota we
all respect each other now yeah that's
what's up not like we're family and
we're sticking together and in the
moment like I was aware but I was still
rolling with it you want it so it's okay
like it's it's still fun to see but
you're totally where you're like this
movie hasn't earned this yet but there's
moments they handle what like when she's
still alive after all that the thing
that saves it as Will Smith's line yeah
he says it you know and like that's I
like that awareness kind of comedy yeah
yeah I think that this that's a nice
thing they've borrowed from I think I
think Deadpool's helped is it that even
to and it makes that moment more smooth
it's like we're all thinking it and and
the movie yeah so it's kind of okay and
what those get some great scenes in it
like I love how he does become the
leader of the Suicide Squad because it's
done
in a natural way when the helicopter
first crashes Will Smith is talking with
Harley Quinn and they're all trying to
figure out when the rest of the squad is
like how the [ __ ] do we get out of here
they're just gonna kill us by the end
but the way how Deadshot gets lured in
because when he sees like those are
weights someone from Collider another of
you call them like the putting the the
putty bill the villains from this Power
Rangers is kind of what they are like
what are these they're cool but yeah you
never quite get one there and they're
just these kind of like black globular
beings with these lights on their head
that's kind of what makes when when the
doctor comes back after they destroy
enchantress or whatever get rid of her
kind of disappointed because all these
henchmen are human beings yeah that
chant just put under their control and
then they're just like okay we're gonna
kill kill the [ __ ] yeah we're gonna
slice their heads in half and [ __ ] and
then enchantress when she you know loses
the battle I like that rick flagg lost I
thought that was a cool choice that he
lost that she's not gonna come back and
because because this guy's been in like
a dark secretive world and this
relationship has not been really
beneficial for him yeah yeah he's like
still in love with her and I thought
that would have been a great sense of
loss but then she comes back I'm like a
little bit too much because especially
when he crushes when he chooses to crush
the heart like they played that or at
least he played that in a way that was
very it felt really natural to me
because they could have milked that for
like the ha the suspense of Legolas
staring back and forth like he goes for
it the way it seems like that character
would and then to bring her back is like
ah we just missed out on an opportunity
for this character to get so much more
interesting like that would be closure
in a weird way because yeah shows he
knew what he was doing and he did her
which you know yeah went for enchantress
Algrim I know if you brought in chanters
back later down the road but of this
story I felt like let her die live for
hit for Rick flags a character effect
let her die that's what I wanted cuz
also just from a movie sample if you
leave us at least one thing that tugs
our heart string a little bit that
makes your movie more memorable yeah
exactly if you felt happy because Will
Smith gets to at least have a
relationship with his daughter again you
can also feel kind of bad that rick
flagg like if we're gonna do this again
I wonder how Rick's doing this movie is
not it doesn't seem like it's concerned
with just coddling you and making you
happy all the time
I like that shot and Rick Flagg and when
they became friends by the end yeah that
was the most believable dad worst night
friends but there's a level of respect
by the end like a strong level of
understanding and respect because they
both get moments to prove them yeah cuz
that moment where like he's with his
daughter is a great scene and I love how
his daughters Deadshot is dead her dad
is just a killer when the guys come in
to like cuff him up like on these chains
he's like what do you think like how
rick flagg stop son
yeah and rick flagg i joke Kenema that
was great like addition to this yes he's
like the one character who's not that
average so that it's not this trailer
and i think it's a great addition to the
team he's very natural yeah that's a
good actual again I felt like all the
other soldiers should have gotten killed
off except for him that was one of my
things that I was kind of like bothered
by by this movie was the Suicide Squad
not until the very end got it just be
the Suicide Squad when they turn it on
in chapters through most of the movie
The Suicide Squad has all these other
soldiers backing them up as well yeah
and these soldiers seem like you just
get like a couple more soldiers in there
you take out boomerang and Killer Croc
and they'll probably be more effective
for then I mean Killer Croc yeah it does
seem like this movie only lets them all
off the leash the one time granted it's
not the same thing but if you watch like
the Avengers like that's building a team
of people who don't want to be on a team
but it lets them off the leash
periodically to see how they all do
together this time yeah and this movie
doesn't at least in this form doesn't
really have that it's them versus the
the you know operative guys yeah with
for most of it until finally at the end
the situation is so huge that they kind
of have to work yeah exactly it's just
yeah it makes for a less satisfying
team-up you know which is and I liked
them I did like the music that you know
the soundtracks that David Ayer chose
for this movie I thought sometimes the
music was a little cool
the actual scene and those those were
the times because because the thing is I
think the music's really cool and using
popular songs I thought it what about
you have the House of the Rising Sun at
the beginning I was like this is cool
actually yeah yeah that felt like
something that was intentional but it
seemed like a lot of there were at least
a good handful of times where I felt
like this scene probably had score over
it first and then they took it out and
put a cool yeah yeah because sometimes
the cool songs don't work yeah yeah the
one that really stood out to me that
didn't work was the Eminem one and
specifically because this movie is pg-13
and you're taking this without me song
that is very vulgar and rude and
offensive and then the annotated you
know we in a bad way they edited the
song badly it just doesn't want you know
the structure you're a mediator and I
think if you don't know the structure
you would be like there's something off
about this sounds like it's like it's on
the way it's like edited around the song
it's not like they just leave out a cuss
word or two yeah it's like say takes
segments and they switch them around and
stuff that's the thing that always pulls
me out of movies is whenever they use a
popular song and they restructure it
like even if I haven't heard it I can
usually tell that that's not where the
pieces were supposed to go Eminem song
belongs in a hard-r movie and this movie
feels like it really wants to know
that's and that's the thing that sucks
is that Dave it's like cuz you gotta
care for like katana katana gets her
cool flashback moment I like her story
husband died with this or that she
carries we sold it over there
but like see what we got yeah and she's
really she's [ __ ] awesome and her
skills and sniper brush though when you
got a girl like slicing throats and
stabbing people with a sword you need
some blood and especially in this day
and age yeah I'm not all about gritty
hard are comic-book movies but this
movie seemed like to fulfill its true
spirit that's kind of what you needed
know if you got yeah I really feel like
it would have been okay and I feel like
David Ayers all of his films including
is this most of the screenplays he's
ridden or rated are except for like
fasten the fury the first one
knows about family I like the moments we
got with Jared Leto but it's not enough
for me to decide whether or not I really
like him as the Joker yeah he's stuck
with me but I don't know how I feel if I
think his performance is great or not
cuz it's kind of like like he gets more
screen time than Batman in this movie
but imagine if that was the first time
we're seeing Batman introduced in the DC
Cinematic Universe we'd be like he's a
cool Batman yeah not enough though to
know if he's gonna really like kill it
as Batman well that's a no that's
another editing thing is like the first
couple times we see Joker are longer
scenes where we really get to watch him
yeah it seems like his Jared Leto's
Joker as a Joker that you need to watch
for a minute or two to really see how he
behaves and so when he's in shorter
scenes kind of comes across weird yeah
it just leaves you go I want weights
that don't don't just jump ahead so
quick and and because he kind of just
pops into the rest of the movie like
it's kind of a treat but he does feel
sort of tacked on yeah he feels like a
tactile marketing ploy for the film
because most people don't know these
other characters and Harley Quinn was
really exciting because you're like Oh
Joker didn't mean it to because like
acid is here it feels like somebody they
clearly put a lot of effort into the
Joker but it doesn't feel necessary no
it doesn't it's like his whole mission
is not that necessary yeah actually it's
not necessary at all Israel because that
time you can fill this mission which is
a cool moment like oh we hijacked Amanda
Waller's a helicopter is there one thing
with this is like why do people trust
the Joker like why do people follow this
guy yeah you know like that's something
that Dark Knight does really well and
and and Tim Burton's Batman does really
well is like you see this guy's a
criminal [ __ ] genius yeah and why
people will follow it I was like okay
you gotta Arkham cool why he was like
really other than like how is he the
Clown Prince of Crime yes he's the Joker
or like or is he literally like a
mastermind criminal who she's looking
the same guy who likes the hijack
shouldn't shoot him up and stuff you
know it's it's weird it's like he
doesn't see what he does any clever
planning he looks and he acts like like
a kingpin of some kind but the movie
never gives you anything to support
exactly now's my issue with it
and then by the time you rest use Harley
Quinn it's like last for like 30 seconds
Deadshot's like okay I'll shoot her
[ __ ] did not change am I good killer
was cool
but then the plane gets hit they crash
she thinks Joker's dead never see him
again and then she just goes back to the
Suicide Squad yeah and it's like wait we
just kept cutting back to Joker
periodically and for him go meaning
Harley back it gets Harley back for 30
seconds and then the movie just yeah and
that's what me this doesn't change
anything and this was frustrating about
trailers because like you you see that
image and I don't know if I'm just
misinterpreting something but like it
looks like they have like a burned up
Joker somewhere in that trailer and I
know people have talked about it because
it's something that happens in the
comics I believe so the helicopter goes
down I was fully expecting another
portion of this movie were they he
finally collides with the suit yeah
that's grab but he just disappears and
then you're like why did we why was this
like an annoying thing that happened in
their day and I did like how they all
got what they wanted in the end except
for boomerang but Killer Croc it was a
nice sight like I like killer crotch
moment where Amanda Waller they rescue
her everyone's like what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like they're all thinking it but Killer
Croc finally says something like then he
gets his television so you watch MTV
you can watch - yeah Harley Quinn gets
her coffee machine yeah I like how they
asked her like stupid things and they
got them and they're satisfied with that
shot asked her like the big thing and he
gets it [ __ ] Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne's
big credit scene
oh yeah yeah people really like it I
don't I yeah I was like I thought he had
this information I thought he would have
been on this yeah that Lex Luthor had
the informated lecture to steal the
information from Amanda Waller steam or
something
I thought it was our I was kind of
overwhelming yeah it was it was
underwhelming and it was just like oh
yeah yeah I know you guys are doing
justice
really really Centralia you don't even
remind me that there are a couple cool
questions that it does raise up I mean I
am curious about his relationship with
Amanda Waller now and and how deep that
runs but I almost would have liked
something that hints at more Suicide
Squad than something that just hits it
justice league yeah you know I found a
sex line directed that scene with flash
did you really yeah did something right
alright guys we were finally done
talking about Suicide Squad it don't
want to talk about it anymore for the
rest of my life ever if you're new to
this channel subscribe did become a
reject John Jerry is his Twitter and
Instagram root facebook.com slash Blum
House social media manager there and
facebook.com slash the real rejects what
pizza please make a pizza alright
there's a place to get pizza then she
just gets charged like a hundred dollars
hundred dollar identity fraud a hundred
new separate purchases equaling a
hundred dollars of Domino's someone
jacked your Lord a pizza party kids
invite your friends stole some dudes
debit card information and then we're
gonna spend $200 on tickets you joke
done yeah it's fine cut the camera I
thought you already got it alright